last night madame deputy speaker we aim
to relocate the first people from our
country who arrived here through
dangerous and illegal means including by
small boat
over the course of this week many and
various claims to prevent relocation
have been brought forward
now madam deputy speaker i welcome the
decisions of our domestic courts the
high court the court of appeal
and supreme court to uphold our right to
send the flight
however following a decision by an
out-of-hours judge in the european court
of human rights in strasbourg minutes
before our flight's departure the final
individuals remaining on the flight had
their removal directions paused while
their claims were considered
i want to make something absolutely
clear today imagine deputy speaker the
european court of human rights did not
rule that the policy or relocations were
unlawful
but they prohibited the removal of three
of those on last night's flight those
prohibitions
last for different time periods but are
not an absolute bar
on their transfer to rwanda
anyone who's been ordered to be released
by the courts will be tagged while we
continue to progress their relocation
while this decision by the strasbourg
court to intervene was disappointing and
surprising given the repeated and
considered judgments to the country in
our domestic cause we remain committed
to this policy
these repeated legal barriers are madam
deputy speaker very similar to those
that we experience with all other
removal flights and we believe that we
are fully compliant with our domestic
and international obligations and
preparations for our future flights and
the next flights have already begun
our domestic courts were off the view
that the flight could go ahead
madame deputy speaker the case for our
partnership with veranda bears repeating
we are a generous and welcoming country
as has been shown time and time again
over 20 000 people have used safe and
legal routes to come to the uk since
2015
and most recently madam deputy speaker
britons have opened their hearts and
their homes to afghan nationals and
ukraine national ukrainian nationals
but our capacity to help those in need
is severely compromised by those who
come here illegally and as we've
discussed in this house many many times
who seek to jump the queue because they
can afford to pay the people smugglers
it is illegal it is not necessary
because they are coming from other safe
countries
it is not fair either on those who play
by the rules or on the british taxpayers
who have to foot this bill
we cannot keep on spending nearly five
million pounds a day on accommodation
including that of hotels we cannot
accept this intolerable pressure on
public services and local communities it
makes us less safe as a nation because
those who come here illegally do not
have the regularized checks or even the
regular status and because evil people
smuggling gangs use the proceeds of
their ill-gotten gains to fund other
appalling crimes that undermine the
security of our country
it is also legally dangerous for those
who are smuggled
people have drowned at sea
suffocated in lorries and perish
crossing territories
the in the humane decent and moral
response to all of this is simply not to
stand by and let people down or to be
sold into slavery or to be smuggled but
to stop this
and with that madame deputy speaker
inaction is not an option
or at least not a morally responsible
one
this is as i've said repeatedly a
complex long-standing problem
the global asylum system is broken and
between 80 to 100 million people are now
displaced and others are on the move
seeking better economic opportunities
and an international problem requires
international solutions
the uk
the the uk and rwanda have shown the way
forward by working together
and this partnership sends a clear
message that illegal entry will not be
tolerated madam deputy speaker while
offering a practical humane way forward
for those who arrived to the uk by
illegal roots
it has saddened me madam deputy speaker
to see rwanda so terribly misrepresented
introduced in his centuries
it is another example of how all too
often critics not only don't know what
they're speaking about but seek to
vilify another international country
that has a good track record when it
comes to refugees and stepping up to
international responsibilities the
rwandan madam deputy speaker is a safe
and secure country
with an outstanding track record of
supporting refugees and asylum seekers
and indeed we are proud that we are
working together proud that the uk is
investing in rwanda and helping that
great country to thrive i'm proud that
those who are relocated to rwanda will
have an opportunity to thrive as well
they will be given generous support
including language skills vocational
training and help with starting their
own businesses or finding employment
but of course i'm afraid and deputy
speaker the usual suspects
with the blessings of honourable and
right honourable members opposite have
set thought to camp
set out the thought
and even campaign against these efforts
and with that madam deputy speaker the
will of the british people
it would be wrong to issue a running
commentary over ongoing cases but madam
deputy speaker i would like to say this
this government will not be deterred
from doing the right thing we will not
be put off by the inevitable legal
last-minute challenges nor we will allow
mobs madam deputy speaker to block
removals we will not stand idly by and
let organized crime gangs who are
despicable in their nature and their
conduct evil people treat human beings
as cargo
we will not accept that we have no right
to control our borders madam deputy
speaker we will do everything necessary
to keep this country safe and we will
continue our long and proud tradition of
helping those in genuine need
now many of us have met refugees both
abroad and on british soil and listen to
the stories that are quite frankly
chilling and heartbreaking but of course
it suits the benches opposite to pretend
that this side of the house doesn't care
but madame deputy speaker as you refer
to in the earlier point of order this on
this side of the house such accusations
are a grotesque slur
and let me tell you madam deputy speaker
what is truly chilling is listening to
opponents on going on about how awful
this policy is while offering no
practical solutions our lives are being
lost helping develop safe and legal
routes to this country for those who
really need them is absolutely at the
heart of this government's work and
having overseen efforts to bring to the
uk thousands of people in absolute need
including from hong kong syria
afghanistan and ukraine and i am the
first to say that controlled immigration
is good for our country outstanding for
our country including that by refugees
but madam deputy speaker we simply have
to focus on the support of those who
need it the most and not those who have
picked the uk as a destination over a
safe country like france
and it is no use pretending that they
are fleeing persecution when they are
traveling from a safe country because
our capacity to help is not infinite and
public support for the asylum system
will be fatally undermined if we do not
act and along with the critics the
critics of the
migration and economic development
partnership have no alternative proposal
to deal with uncontrolled immigration
and like on so many other issues the
party's opposite the labour party and
the snp are on the wrong side of the
argument and we will only see with their
arguments public trust in the system
being corroded that is irresponsible and
utterly indifferent to those who we seek
to help and support now madam deputy
speaker i have always said that i will
look at all proposals to reduce illegal
migration um an illegal entry to our
country and even those that the opposite
benches might prepare to put forward but
we still uh wait for them however
however well he says that however
fundamentally they don't think there is
a problem and that is why they don't
have a solution because they still
remain and stand for open borders pure
and simple
meanwhile this government wants to get
on with delivering not just on what the
british people want but reforming our
systems so yes so that they are firm but
equally madame deputy speaker so that
they are fair to those who pay for them
and fare on those who need our help and
support